we could end the pandemic as a pandemic
by the fourth of July if we took action
right now wouldn't mean we have no new
cases certainly but we could end the
pandemic phase I guess we would call it
and I know that many of you know we've
already missed a number of opportunities
to do this back on March 5th I'm being
very generous by looking at March 5th we
had all the information we needed about
the spread of the virus we should have
taken immediate action Donald Trump
should have said to all 50 governors
listen we need a 50-state stay at home
order we have some very very difficult
days ahead but we will be better off if
we all do this now instead on March 5th
we did nothing on March 5th we ended up
doing only 500 or so tests by March 15th
we were still only doing about a
thousand tests a day by March 25th we
were finally up to 80,000 tests which
was still not nearly enough we were so
behind and still to this day we aren't
doing enough tests and we don't have any
federal contact tracing initiative so
opportunities have come and gone but
once again we have an opportunity in
front of us to deal with what we are
dealing with right now and we could be
in very good shape nationally by July
4th Alex Tabarrok and Puja ole haver
wrote a really good piece in The
Washington Post outlining the by pardons
bipartisan plan that they participated
in putting together and it's important
that this plan considers the medical and
the economic I've been taking the
economic seriously from day one the
right has been having a grand old time
framing leftists as not caring about the
economy as not caring about unemployment
not caring about economic destruction
the truth is I and most serious leftists
have been concerned from day one with
the economy and the reality is that six
months of rolling doclock downs in some
parts of the country some open-close
open-close
that's not going to be good for the
economy either there's a plan that's
been written and the test the testing
element is a big part of that plan we
need to dramatically increase testing
how innovative it's not it's not
surprising but we are still not testing
and
but the test levels are very
specifically outlined by this plan we
need to be testing everyone who has
symptoms and all of their contacts
contacts and have enough capacity for
what we call surveillance testing people
just go in even without symptoms because
there is such a symptomatic spread we
need everyone who has the disease and
their contacts self isolate we may need
hotel rooms for people to be able to
self isolate depending on their
situation at home
we may need stipends for people who are
self isolating while they cannot work
and what the plan does that is really
important is it divides the country into
three types of zones green zones yellow
zones and red zones and the plan
acknowledges which a lot of
right-wingers want that rural Montana
doesn't have to do the same thing that
New York City needs to do green zone
would mean fewer than one in 36 thousand
are infected you can do large gatherings
in green zones you don't need a mask in
green zones unless you are part of or
around folks who are in vulnerable
populations
you need one test per day for every
10,000 people in green zones and five
contact tracers for every hundred
thousand people that is not a lot for
the green zones now right now there are
not very many green zones two weeks ago
we could have had 19 million Americans
in green zones based on our testing
levels right now we don't have any
active green zones that are meeting
these requirements then we get the
yellow zones yellow zones are for most
of the country right now 298 million
Americans right now would be in what we
call yellow zones that's where the
disease prevalence is somewhere between
point zero zero two percent and 1
percent okay in the yellow zones the
economy can reopen mandatory masks for
everyone and you need 2,500 tests tests
for each daily death plus much more
contact tracing you need to have enough
contact tracing to contact every person
who's been in touch with an infected
individual within
twelve hours why within 12 hours because
if you wait three days it's too late and
those people have been going around
potentially spreading the disease so for
example based on the last few days of
deaths New Jersey would need 250,000
tests per day but Maryland would only
need 87,000 tests per day these are much
bigger numbers than what we have but
these are not cartoonishly high numbers
based on on the models that we've seen
so you've got your green zones and your
yellow zones then you've got your red
zones red zones are there more than 1%
of the population is infected right now
there are about 30 million people in
that situation that's just under 10% of
the country so in those red zones you
have everything that the yellow zones
have in terms of testing and tracing but
you also have a stay at home order if
you follow it the red zone becomes
yellow relatively quickly by four weeks
in most analyses and then you move to
yellow and then the whole country could
be at minimum at yellow by the fourth of
July that means the whole country could
be open although yellow zones would
still have more precautions like
mandatory masks and we could be at Green
by the end of the summer we're not even
close on testing we're now testing about
350,000 375-thousand a day we need
somewhere between 3 and 5 million a day
and based on current numbers were
nowhere near that this can be done but
we're way behind if we started today we
could be in pretty good shape for moving
red zones to yellow and yellow to green
heavily around the 4th of July
seems to be no political desire at the
federal government
Trump's acting like we won he's talking
about SuperDuper missiles but this is a
plan that works test trace and isolate
North Korea I'm sorry
South Korea succeeded with it the
earliest New Zealand did it Taiwan did
it Greece had a milder version and they
still did it although it took a little
bit longer Greece's looking at opening
up for travel very very soon
prevention is cheaper than the cure
testing is cheaper than both the
economic destruction and the costs of
treating way more sick people
here's another plan the plan is
based on right now it's mid-may we could
do this we could be in very good shape
by July 4th